we got a lot of show to do tonight and
not a lot of time to do it in we're very
tight no wasting time tonight no wasting
time the producer just crazy what are
you doing that for all right folks
it's no secret it's no secret at all
that the business this is something I
want to talk about it means a lot to me
the business of network television has
gotten more and more cutthroat every day
think about it there's more and more
channels now that are available cable
satellite so what happens is network
profits keep dwindling they get smaller
and smaller NBC still makes money but
not as much as they used to make was a
result NBC has been slashing budgets
left and right yeah all the shows and
since we're on late at night guess what
they come to us we're one of the first
shows they come to and they say can you
lose some of the money in the budget
we're gonna have to cut you back a
little bit which is fair it's fine but
we thought we'd be honest with our
audience and show you some of the ways
we're tightening our belts and a little
piece for calling late-night budget cuts
[Applause]
[Music]
first budget cut is that song that
what's that gone I never know what that
is well to begin I have to say I want to
go through some of the budget cuts I
have to say I think some of the cuts NBC
has been making around here outrageous
for example the chair I'm sitting on now
from the front it looks like a normal
nice chair but they switched it the
other day to save money
check out my chair from behind it's
ridiculous this is this tape goes we're
all dead all right NBC here's another
one NBC is so obsessed with saving money
they're even cutting back on my wardrobe
budget that's right now even though the
suits I wear on the show are handmade
and beautiful those penny-pinchers have
found a way to save money on the suits
check it out so folks as you can see we
have a terrific show tonight we got
great guests really fun comedy we'll
take a break we'll be right back after
these messages
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah yeah it's called the abdomenizer
yeah but someone asked how I managed to
look so I guess no one did you know one
thing that costs a lot because cost a
ton of money is the headset system that
our director in the booth uses to
communicate with the cameramen out here
in the studio
well NBC is making us replace that
headset system with a far less expensive
system check out what happens now when I
look from camera one to camera two and
the director has to switch let's do that
right now and go camera two camera two
another budget cut would be the special
effects pigeon by the way there it is
right there
that's a raven arguing with me now most
of you probably don't realize this but
the staff here at late night keeps bunny
rabbits around the office just for fun
this is something we've been doing since
the very beginning of the show we keep
bunny rabbits around everyone plays with
them it's lots of fun it's good for
morale and they're adorable and cuddly
everyone enjoys them but the word came
down the other day from corporate that
they're too expensive and that we have
to give up one of the bunnies for
adoption and I know it's too bad there
they are they're gorgeous and this is
gonna be a really tough decision oh
what's so tough about it your lanky bean
what you said all you bunnies you're all
so cute Oh boohoo you gotta get rid of a
cute bunny what sort of a wuss are you
just pick one okay she said it's not
that easy shut up pick a bunny and stop
being a douchebag
all right then well I pick you me why'd
you pick me crap face all right get him
out of here guys just take a waik you
pay you freak
now folks one of the show's biggest
expenses is accommodating the wishes of
our most famous guests all right well we
have a big top name guest here a big
movie star we have to pay top dollar to
fly them in first-class put them up in
an expensive hotel it adds up so we've
been trying to get less famous guests
who won't make such outrageous demands
check out this interview from last week
it's a real pleasure having you on the
show you want to tell us about your new
film
you shot this movie mostly in Europe a
lot of it new Italy is that right Paul
don't worry you got to you got lunch
especially don't ya that's story what a
what a really what you hear about is
that working with Angelina Jolie and
Joanna tell me yeah yeah you work with
Angelina Jolie tell us something about
her place all right with my unit Jolie
hey yeah okay
now speaking of budget cuts NBC has
ordered us to get rid of our audience
security that's right so Jim Steve I'm
sorry we got to let you guys go
yeah I'm sorry we don't have the money
you're free to go sorry about that we
just had to but Conan without audience
security this crowd of fans is going to
rush the stage and demand your autograph
[Applause]
okay well anyway you know folks our
budgets been cut so much we're having
trouble paying the rent this month it's
true so we're doing everything we can to
hide from our show's landlord huh yeah
from our show's landlord there you go
good cue co-come friendly we've cut back
on the cueing - don't you go back and
we'll try that again I tell you we've
had to cut things back so much we're
doing everything we can to hide from our
show's landlord huh Conan yeah didn't
expect to see you well he's on his way
mr. slotnick is coming oh my god mr.
slotnick scumming here we go come on
Conan Conan no mr. Coons gone for the
day
is late night with Bob Kirk Linton goon
Chou are you sure yeah yeah have you met
the Philip wash turn seven my mistake
well if you see : tell him I want my
rent
I should leave this this looks hot all
right everything around here really is
crappy this isn't a bit at all and
here's our final budget cut folks you
see one of our most popular characters
is vomiting Kermit that's right well
yeah unfortunately unfortunately the
price of Kermit's vomit has skyrocketed
that stuff's not cheap so because of the
budget cuts from now on vomiting Kermit
can only be dry retching Kermit take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
really oh wait wait this is this folks
is good news I'm being told that while
vomiting Kermit is too expensive we do
still have money for bulimic Grover
here's bulimic Grover
[Applause]
I'm glad Conan O'Brien's not here to see
that horrible sketch because his tenders
are much higher folks we'll take a break
when we come back Steve Zahn